so we have one two three four five
blueberries here so we have five
blueberries and we have one two three
cherries three cherries now if I wanted
to figure out the total number of fruit
that I have here I could say the total
number of pieces of fruit what should I
do
should I add five plus three so should I
add five plus three or should I subtract
should I do 5 minus three to get the
total number of fruit that I have and I
encourage you to pause the video now and
try to think about it on your own well
if I want the total number of fruit I'm
starting with five blueberries and now I
have three more I'm going to add three
I'm going to get a larger number of
fruit I start with five I'm going to
have three more so I am going to add
three and so how many blueberries do I
have well what's five plus three it's
one two three four five six seven eight
pieces of fruit eight pieces of fruit
now what would 5-3 have meant what would
five minus three
five minus three what would that mean
well you could imagine starting off with
five pieces of fruit let me copy and
paste that copy and paste that so if you
start with five pieces of fruit and now
if you're subtracting three this means
taking away three of your fruit so take
away one take away two and take away
three so how many are you left with well
you're just left with these one two
right over here so 5 minus 3 is 2 so if
someone says hey I have five blueberries
then I have 3 more cherries how many
pieces of fruit well now I'm going to be
adding but if someone says I have five
blueberries and then I ate three of them
how many
do I have left well then you have to
left